[Music]
on this Friday night another Canadian
politician whose sources allege was part
of a Chinese interference Network the
details of the claims and the Ontario
mpp's denials this is a force a cutic
Global News investigates
legal problem why Donald Trump will
likely get hit with criminal charges and
what that could mean for his bid for the
White House
cracking down on migrants the UK's
contentious plan to curb illegal
immigration
plus fighting racism using virtual
reality he's so touchy about his name to
address a very real problem
[Music]
for an answer reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with an update on a global news
investigation into allegations of
foreign interference in Canada's 2019
federal election intelligence sources
have identified several alleged members
of a covert network that sources say
facilitated the transfer of funds from
the Chinese Consulate and sources say
the recipients included a member of Doug
Ford's Ontario conservative government
Jeff sempel has the exclusive details in
tonight's top story
[Applause]
when Doug Ford's Ontario conservatives
swept to power in 2018 a little-known
candidate quietly made history I'm
fortunate to have one of the best mpps
around in Ontario
Vincent my friend Vincent Ka became the
first immigrant from mainland China to
be elected Ontario conservative MPP the
member for Don Valley North
thank you Mr Speaker but intelligence
sources say the MPP was also part of an
alleged foreign interference Network to
advance beijing's political agenda
during the 2019 federal election
campaign sources say the Chinese
Consulate transferred around 250
thousand dollars through a network it
involved at least 11 Federal candidates
campaign staffers and other politicians
both liberal and conservative including
liberal MP Han dong who has denied the
allegations the funds were allegedly
sent first through a businessman Wei
Chang Yi then sources say the money
flowed to a federal candidate staff
member and taka who received about fifty
thousand dollars okay thank you I think
it was the allegations stem from
interviews with Canadian intelligence
sources including a senior official with
detailed awareness of the cesus
investigations Global News is not able
to independently verify the allegations
made by ceases against Kawai ordong this
is a false acquisition this is I told
him in the email already you say it's
racism it's racist because I was born in
China because I come from China so you
never received fifty thousand dollars
from the Toronto concert this is how
they always play the uh race card the
use of racism
you know label someone racism
to distract
the real issue here Jack Jay is the
editor of this Toronto area Chinese
newspaper this is a story we we produced
he's produced reports which are banned
on the popular Chinese messaging app
WeChat investigating because political
activities he says Ka has appeared at
events with Chinese Consulate officials
and pro-beijing groups like The Tibetan
Association of Canada which promotes
Chinese rule in Tibet so this is very
outrageous there is so many conflict of
interest in a statement Ka said he has a
responsibility of attending a multitude
of events hosted by a wide range of
ethnic communities to maintain a
relationship with all his constituents
he believed the Tibetan Association was
simply another group that supported
Tibetan Canadians
the other alleged intermediary
businessman Wei Chang Yi shown here in
2014 also denied any involvement in a
written statement he called the report a
complete fabrication inexplicable and
total nonsense liberal NP Han dong wrote
I am unaware of the claims provided to
you by alleged sources which contains
seriously inaccurate information we know
there is ongoing interference in Canada
the Prime Minister publicly supported
dung and said the alleged interference
in the 2019 election did not influence
the overall outcome Trudeau promised to
name a special rapporteur to investigate
the claims but stopped short of calling
a full public inquiry Trudeau government
should be open answer this question it's
not just for the security of uh or
democracy of our country it's also for
Chinese Community itself now unlike the
UK and Australia Canada has no foreign
interference legislation meaning there's
nothing illegal per se about
transferring money in the way this
network is alleged to have done
Jeff Semple Global News Toronto
and a minor cabinet Shuffle tonight
means Vincent Ka is out as a public and
Business Service delivery ministers
parliamentary assistant the Ontario
premier's office says in part while the
allegations against Mr Ka are not proven
they're serious and deserve his full and
undivided attention as he works to clear
his name
Beijing took aim at Ottawa today
accusing Canada of smearing its
reputation over allegations Chinese
government officials are secretly
running two so-called police stations in
Quebec in a daily briefing China's
foreign Ministry said Beijing has been
abiding by international law and called
on Canada to stop sensationalizing and
hyping the matter yesterday RCMP in
Quebec confirmed they were investigating
what they call foreign state-backed
criminal activities at two centers in
Montreal and Brossard a suburb south of
the city it's believed Beijing has set
up more than 100 of them around the
world to monitor harass and in some
cases repatriate Chinese citizens living
abroad that investigation adds to the
mounting allegations of Chinese
interference in Canada's Internal
Affairs and fuels the growing calls for
the federal government to take action
today Ottawa announced the beginning of
a long-awaited tool to help fight
foreign interference but as Mackenzie
gray reports for many it's too little
too late
foreign
it's the first step of a recent promise
to fight foreign interference I'm
announcing the launch of consultations
to guide how we will set up a new
foreign influenced transparency registry
in Canada the goal of a registry to shed
light on individuals paid to influence
the Canadian political process on behalf
of other states like China Russia or
Iran country's intelligence officials
have warned for years our meddling
Canadian Affairs but the consultations
don't come with a timeline for
legislation we have laid the foundation
for a conversation that will be sure
that we get this mechanism right it is
not an uncomplicated straightforward
exercise
that conversation has already been
happening in the senate or a bill to
create the new tool was proposed over a
year ago legislation the public safety
Minister said he supported I certainly
think that's an idea that that merits a
study I agree that this is oppressing
and urgent issue a key concern how to
make sure various diaspora are not
unfairly targeted by a potential
registry we have a great responsibility
to ensure that we are not unfairly or
unintentionally creating a cloud that
hovers over an entire Community but
experts from those communities want the
government to bring in the new tool the
Chinese Canadian Community welcome this
foreign agent registry
a monitor a registry on a foreign agent
is not the same as a registry on all
Chinese Canadians the idea of a registry
isn't a new one the US has had one since
the 1930s and recently Australia
implemented one I think the advantage is
more public relations but this former
thesis intelligence official believes
legislation to deter foreign
interference would be more powerful than
a registry the enablers and facilitators
of foreign influence activities
their activities are generally
clandestine they're not going to be
signing up for a registry once a
consultation period closes in two months
the government will turn to drafting
legislation but today Marco Mendocino
wouldn't say if the Liberals would
commit to having the registry in place
in time for the next election nathu
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
Mackenzie China's Xi Jinping has secured
a historic third term as president
following a largely ceremonial vote at
the national people's Congress in
Beijing
the nearly 3 000 member Congress voted
unanimously for Xi Jinping to serve
another five-year term as president the
unprecedented vote comes after the
Chinese legislature moved to abolish a
two-term limit on the presidency in 2018
putting XI on track to remain in power
for life
the federal government is clawing back
more than 82 million dollars in health
transfers to eight provinces the health
Minister says some patients are being
charged for medically necessary care
it is critical that access to medically
necessary Services whether provided in
person or virtually remains based on
medical need and free of charge
duclow says he is concerned some people
have been paying out of pocket for
ultrasounds MRIs and CT scans he sent
letters to all provinces and territories
warning medically necessary Health Care
is covered no matter where you live
Health Care will be a big part of the
2023 federal budget today Finance
Minister Christa Freeland announced it
will be released on March 28th she says
the government is focused on fiscal
restraint and won't be pouring fuel on
the Flames of inflation
Google Canada says it will end its test
of blocking news search results for some
Canadians the test started early last
month in response to legislation that
would see big tech companies pay news
organizations for linking content it led
to MPS berating Google Canada's managing
director during a committee meeting in
Ottawa today
I think that you intentionally intended
to make Canadians aware of it so that we
would be afraid to pass c18 in the
Senate because of the threat that you
would block news content we're
conducting tests to understand product
impact on legislation that's not
finished
Google's test affected all types of news
and impacted an estimated 1.2 million
Canadian users the test ends on March
16th
Ottawa has now approved westjet's
takeover of sun wing Airlines clearing
the runway for a major shake-up in the
airline industry transportation Minister
Omar Al gabra signed off on the deal
today despite concerns raised by
Canada's competition Watchdog suggesting
the merger will likely result in higher
airfares and reduce Services the deal
was first announced in March of 2022.
the British prime minister was in Paris
today announcing a new deal to tackle
the migrant crisis Rishi sunak says
Britain will pay France nearly 800
million dollars to help stop migrants
from traveling in small boats across the
English Channel
we're announcing a new Detention Center
in northern France a new Command Center
bringing our enforcement teams together
in one place for the first time and an
extra 500 new officers patrolling French
beaches
sunak says there will also be more
drones and surveillance to help
intercept migrants France is also
expected to contribute funding critics
though say the plan won't work the UN
says it breaches international law as
Redmond Shannon reports no matter what
sunac hopes the Hardline approach will
give him a boost in the polls
good evening
three simple words on a lectern to
articulate what could be a complex legal
process for British prime minister Rishi
sunak entering the UK illegally in small
boats
has more than quadrupled in just the
last two years 45
000 people cross the English Channel
this way last year almost all applied
for Asylum even those from relatively
safe countries like Albania we will
detain those who come here illegally and
then remove them in weeks either to
their own country if it is safe to do so
or to a safe Third Country like Rwanda
Rwanda a reference to a deal the UK made
to send Asylum Seekers to the east
African nation and into its immigration
system that plan is currently bogged
down in the courts the British interior
Minister admits this proposal could face
the same fate we are also pushing the
boundaries and we're testing Innovative
and novel legal arguments the United
Nations Refugee agency says the plan
would be a clear breach of its Refugee
convention immigration experts say it
would effectively treat Asylum Seekers
as criminals if such removal is not in
line with the European convention then
the the United Kingdom might have to
withdraw from the European convention in
human rights Belarus Russia and Vatican
City are the only other European
countries that have not signed the
convention for the last 10 years our
government has followed policies based
on deterrence and none of them have any
impacts on people crossing the channel
so why should this be any different on
Wednesday sunak called the British
opposition leader Kier starmer a lefty
lawyer standing in his way if and when
this plan faces legal challenges it's
likely we'll hear more of that rhetoric
from the governing Tories Redmond
Shannon Global News London
coming up Donald Trump may make history
for all the wrong reasons
in the U.S there are signs former
president Donald Trump could be indicted
on criminal charges the case relates to
Trump's alleged role in a hush money
payment to Stormy Daniels our Washington
bureau chief Jackson prosco joins us now
Jackson
me too if Donald Trump is indicted it
would Mark the first time a former
American president has ever been charged
with a crime the case relates to an
alleged 130 thousand dollar hush money
payment made to adult film star Stormy
Daniels just days before the 2016
election Daniels claims she had an
affair with Trump trump denies it in
recent months several people close to
Trump have met with Manhattan
prosecutors including Trump's former
attorney Michael Cohen who's at the
center of the alleged payments to
Daniels The Manhattan district attorney
has now reportedly invited the former
president to testify before a grand jury
as early as next week it's a sign
criminal charges are likely on the way
because New York law requires potential
defendants to be given the option to
testify as far as this charge goes it's
not the most serious chart charge but
look it's something you have to take
seriously and the fact that one
prosecutor makes the decision to indict
might make actually easier for other
prosecutors to make the same decision in
different cases with more serious
consequences now it's expected Trump
will decline the offer to testify but he
still faces multiple other legal
challenges a grand jury in Georgia has
recommended several indictments as
prosecutors there weigh charges in
efforts to interfere in the 2020
election and the justice department has
ongoing Federal investigations underway
including into Trump's role in the
January 6th attack and the classified
documents recovered from his home Trump
of course continues to insist that the
probes are all politically motivated and
he has made it clear that even if he is
indicted he plans to continue his run
for president in 2024. nithu Jackson
prosco in Washington thanks Jackson
shocked and saddened ahead the aftermath
of a deadly shooting in Hamburg Germany
German investigators are searching for a
motive after a lone gunman carried out a
mass shooting killing six people
according to police the shooter a
35-year-old man who later killed himself
was a former member of the Jehovah's
Witness congregation that he targeted
Crystal gomancing Reports on the violent
Rampage and what authorities know about
the suspect
Hamburg police say a former Jehovah's
Witness armed with a legally obtained
semi-automatic gun acted alone
[Music]
we are shocked says the regional
spokesperson for the Jehovah's Witnesses
we found out about this Rampage about an
hour after it happened
cell phone video captured the man
identified by police as Philip F
approaching the building Thursday night
you can hear rounds being fired and you
can see a figure near a window that's
where police say he forced his way into
the building
European media Outlets report the
shooter was carrying a backpack with 20
additional magazines that's roughly 300
bullets all the fatalities are of German
nationality and each died from gunshot
impact it's possible the death toll
could still rise police say at least
four others suffered life-threatening
gunshot wounds Jehovah's Witnesses it's
worth noting do not accept blood
transfusions in Munich the German
Chancellor addressed the tragedy
late last night there was a terrible
incident in my hometown of Hamburg
several people have become victims of a
brutal act of violence authorities
confirmed Friday they were tipped off
about Philip F having a weapon and
possibly struggling with his mental
health
what a shocked saddened also afraid
35 year old shooter turned his gun on
himself after police entered the
building nine empty magazines were
reportedly found near his body
Crystal gemancing Global News London
simulating Solutions next how virtual
reality is being used to tackle a real
world problem
[Music]
virtual reality is often associated with
gaming but it has the power to make
lasting change in the real world too for
the new reality pharah NASA explores how
a Canadian educator is using VR to help
people address racial discrimination in
real time
even though this is virtual reality
interactions like this happen daily in
the real world a classmate asks your
Asian friend to tutor him for his math
exam because they just know math am I
right in VR these avatars help users
explore unconscious bias he's so touchy
about his name Michael Avis specializes
in education and Technology he was
curious to see if the immersive world of
VR could be used in anti-racism training
virtual reality is very good at putting
you into that situation and feeling of
visceral empathy or feeling a connection
it was an idea he'd had for a while but
he saw the need for a tool like this
during the pandemic witnessing his kids
online classes it's Black History Month
there was a lot of sort of they in them
statements and the teacher she's a
wonderful teacher so how do we help her
think about the languages she's using so
Michael partnered with body swaps a VR
and AI company in the UK and together
they created a pro program called let's
talk about race it allows participants
to identify unconscious biases and
practice how to call them out you know
that sounds racist right their program
is one of several VR platforms educating
about race diversity and Equity Courtney
Cogburn wanted to help people understand
structural racism as it affects someone
throughout their life look at your
reflection in the mirror it starts very
early in life and it occurs Across the
Life Course users embody Michael
Sterling a black male as he faces racism
can I help you in three stages of his
life as a child an adolescent and a Yale
graduate in the workforce you must be
our candidate from Yale uh no sir it's
about observing white racism from a
black perspective which is a really
different orientation and not about
performing as a black person as a black
Avatar the VR experience is just one
part of the bigger picture to combat
systemic racism but there are signs it's
effective over the long run Cogburn has
data showing that white participants in
her program experienced a shift in
perspective on issues of racism even 14
weeks later they felt more open to
difficult conversations about race
Farah Nasser in Toronto thanks pharah to
learn more about how VR is helping in
The Fight Against Racism you can watch
pharah's story on the new reality
Saturday at 7 pm right here on global
and that is global national for this
Friday night I'm Nito Garcia tonight's
Air Canada is Cottage pond in moccasin's
Newfoundland and Labrador thanks so much
for watching hope to see you again
tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
thank you